[Applaudissements]
et voilà ça doit bien content que ça va
merci d'être là merci j'ai tout
fracasser avant donc voilà donc voila
merci d'être là je suis très heureux de
vous voir charlie crist sandrine tirek
tout le monde se souvient de ce moment
ça restera un des moments très forts de
la saison de balances ton boss à la
baule est bon et les craintes n'étaient
pas en lait mme cheryl et a relaté pas
encore couchés des mines mis 9 jeux trop
content de voir si tu fais un bisou
bonbons charlie comment tu vas toi je
vais très bien c'est vrai alors tu as
changé d'école jeudi d'école alors tu as
choisi l'école quoi juste après
l'émission
ces textes est concentré on a tendu un
petit peu d'accord mais après la
médiatisation de du plateau ah ouais
c'est fallait changer quoi c'est vrai ça
a été beaucoup mieux après ou pas non
non une catastrophe
qu'est ce qui s'est passé quand vous
êtes retourné à l'école après le passage
sous dambach balance au poste il ya eu
les insultes j'ai pu axe accès à l'école
moi et ma fille je devais récupérer mes
enfants sur le trottoir d'en face n'ont
fallait que j'attende que tous les
mamans seules sorties soient récupérés
oui c'est si même millions parce que
l'on attendait c'est sur décision de qui
du chef de l'établissement
la directrice qui a décidé comme ça
parce qu'en fait quand j'ai ramené
charlie un matin la maman du petit était
là et j'ai eu droit à des doigts
d'honneur dans l'établissement donc ça
reste quand même catholique est là en
étant de vous à moi j'ai dit à la
directrice
regardez et maintenant elle a dit je
prends pas parti un moment soutient que
ça monte ça monte stop et du coup je
suis revenue le midi et on était
interdit de
de l'établissement moi et ma fille ne
pouvait plus entrer votre enfant c'était
fallait que j'attende c'est elle qui
nous rendent l école elle nous a le rang
des deux micros exactement pour
justifier sa rien à la justi étant donné
qu'il y ait des conflits avec votre
maman vous alors déjà c'est la dame qui
me fait le doigt d'honneur
mais c'est moi qu'on pénalise en fait tu
voulais vous dire vous allez au baby
horrible insupportable alors alors qu'on
était passés avec le diocèse aussi un
j'avais rencontré moi j'avais fait des
démarches sur l'école quatre acteurs
voilà le grand directeur dieu s'occupe
de toutes les écoles catholiques donc un
enfant qui frappe est ce un conflit
voilà donc du coup on a rencontré ce
directeur qui nous a bien reçu qui nous
a reçus et la directrice et il y avait
le site il fallait que je me mette
d'accord avec elle donc moi j'ai accepté
le protocole écoles privées travail et
bien j'avais pas envie vraiment d'eux
ils voulaient pas partir donc on a dit
oui sauf que moi j'ai suivi le protocole
sauf que de l'autre côté ça pas suivi
c'est devenu de plus en plus se
compliquer on n'a pas cherché à
comprendre
un matin il m'a dit écoute maman tu sais
quoi on ne peut plus tu peux plus te
faire insulter à l'école je suis
d'accord je change d'école ça c'est fait
on est entré l'été quoi 13h à 15h est
inscrit dans une autre école autre école
est au courant de ce qui s'est passé
les minimes sur en fait charles il est
accueilli comme un autre enfant sans son
jugement sans rien sans rien et ce sera
je vais toujours non publique
ah oui qu'est-ce qu'est ce que l'école
catholique avait peur de quoi de la
médiatisation ils ont ils ont pensé que
ça pouvait exemple d'un amalgame
non pas du tout c'est à la médiatisation
ne sont pas du tout accès pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont eu peur de la stigmatisation
de de l'école catholique un lien avec le
harcèlement cette crise qu'ils ont eu
peur de quoi c'est pas je sais pas je
pense que la directrice dans ses
fonctions n'avaient pas qu'on disait la
première fois quand il y avait subsisté
à ce qu était là a dit qu'il y avait des
directeurs directrices qui était apte à
ce genre d'harcèlement et qui pouvait
nous aider
là il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas
pour elle elle malade elle disait tu à
chaque fois il ya les corps il ya des
par rapport aux gendarmes et tout ça le
disais c'est les gendarmes qui s'occupe
de ça moi je
en fait elle voulait rien celle des deux
savoie vous dire je veux dire à ce que
nous écrivions que c'est au tournant
rouge c'est dans toutes les écoles qui
peut avoir du harcèlement publique
catholique religieuse ou pas il faut le
dire parce que effectivement car si l'on
se sont sentis c'est à dire un peu
pointé du doigt notre émission elle
n'avait pas du tout cette vocation
ça se voit c'est que dans toutes les
écoles de france à des enfants qui peut
te faire harceler
quel que soit l'obédience donc c'est
important de le dire exactement ja dans
l'école publique par exemple où il est
charlie
la maîtresse a pris la décision
elle-même d'eux parlait déjà de 500
mètres charlie est tout de suite dire
voilà ces petits garçons là il a vécu ça
attention non pas du tout elle a demandé
elle a fait charlie nous a expliqué que
vers la récréation elle être posé
question à ce qu'il ya des enfants qui
sont aps qu'il ya ça en tout cas ici
c'est interdit le premier qui fait ça et
se retrouve dans le mur du direct 2
alors il y aura des charges publiques
charlie c'est toi qui a décidé de
changer d'école oui c'est mon cas d'ici
dit de changer d'école parce que ton
pouvait plus tu voulais tu t'es dit je
veux un nouveau départ oui et là tu es
heureux oui je suis très heureux non
maîtresse est très gentille était
camarades aussi once de classe tu étais
très content wyss ça y est maintenant
c'est plus qu'un mauvais souvenir pour
toi weezy plus
ça on sent une parole plus vu rassurant
là que la première fois senti que les
rôles entendu il était assez fébrile
c'était à juste titre et dire oui et là
on sent qu'il est bien il est en pleine
confiance c'est sûr ça fait depuis
décembre
je crois mais pour charlie après après
démission ça se passait mal avez-vous ça
se passait là-bas mais pour lui aussi
non non du tout où charlie en fait par
exemple juste un détail il avait pris un
stylo et l'avait mâchouiller dans la
classe et l'avait du stylo on de
téléphoner vite charlie a mangé son
stylo on a peur qu'il lui arrive quelque
chose des clans cre j'arrivais il y
avait rien à l'eau vite charlier je
trouve qu'il n'est pas bien là mal au
ventre il a en fait ça devenait de plus
en plus on m'a plu tout le temps juste
on prend soin de charles ix un surtout
vous savez bien ça c'est devenu s'était
passé de l'autre côté on savait grâce en
fait la directrice me disait m'a même
dit on ne sait plus quoi faire avec
charlie en fait je pense que la
médiatisation les à les embêter
et je pense qu'ils savent tout ça c'est
ça ça les embête et sur des bas ils
l'ont surprotéger en fait on le
surprotégeant au contraire ça a été une
galère pour lui et salami mal vis-à-vis
des autres camarades ya deux garçons qui
le qui le harcelait et ça et le garçon
qui le harcelaient toujours dans l'école
ou à l'huile tranquille 100 kg et
tranquille même eu affaire à un gendarme
qui m'a bien dire oui le petit avoue
enfin d'autres élèves se font taper
aussi se sont fait taper par ce petit
oui mais les parents
alors après je sais pas un prêt je sais
pas qu'est-ce que je repasse pas là bas
mais on est à 100 mètres de l'autre
école on a des terrains et voilà c'est
chaque année
moi je suis mon côté c'est de l'autre
côté on va très bien en tout cas
emmanuel macron aviez juste un mot là du
harcèlement scolaire on va reparler
d'eux va parler du reste par les juges
sur tout à l'heure mais j'espère
vraiment que ce sera pas une formule
c'est vraiment une priorité
il fait alors il faut dépasser les mots
maintenant finalement il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui c'est charlie je vais temps
en temps je regarde les réseaux sociaux
j'ai vu une dame parce que j'ai eu une
autre émission qui a voulu je suis pas
été sur un plateau mais on a demandé le
après de charlie parce que charlie a
reçu presque plus de deux mille lettres
c'est ça alors il faut répondre des
cadeaux ben pareil on a eu beaucoup de
soutien des gens qui sont
me voir en privé sur messenger pour nous
remercier pour voilà et il a eu lui même
le rôle d'écrire à une petite fille qui
est sous exprime alors c'est si beaucoup
c'est une petite fille qui a quatre ans
sa maman obligé de la droguer avec deux
l'expriment parce que elle a un abus
harcèlement à l'école
elle m'a même me demandez votre numéro
elle voulait vraiment de quoi vous
contacter si charlie qui lui a écrit une
lettre pour leurs essais charlie qui a
écrit une lettre en voyant des petits
cadeaux en lui disant si tu veux me
parler je suis là et la maman toujours à
me parle et qui a le b voilà la petite
fille il a aidé la petite fille à se
tenir et d'autres enfants parce que vaut
finalement le mot harcèlement là
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est pas un mot
qu'on trouve comme ça c'est faut
vraiment développer ça et moi je le
souhaite enfin je le dis à n'importe qui
n'importe quel moment il faut vraiment
quand un enfant me dit j'ai pris une
claque
je suis désolé pour pas dire j'ai pas
fait exprès voilà non tu met une claque
tu fais pas exprès charlie charlie est
ce que tu as quelque chose à dire ce
soir à ceux qui nous regardent que je
sais que tu les as beaucoup remercier
tous les gens qui te sont tous ceux qui
ont soutenu qu'ils ont envoyé des
lettres et envoyer des cadeaux
aujourd'hui ce que tu as quelque chose à
leur dire je viens leur dire merci pour
tout ce qu'ils ont ça t'a fait du bien
oui c'est donc en fait ça t'a fait du
bien mais une de devenir dans cette
émission est ce que c'est ce qui t'a
fait aussi peut-être sauté le pas pour
preuve pour changer d'école et pour
vivre une nouvelle vie on est heureux là
aujourd'hui
tu m'as offert un petit cadeau des
chocolats aussi j'avais prévu un petit
cadeau pour toi c'est une console
c'est à mahdia micro voilà merci
là c'est dans la presse elle a battu par
avec ses la switch comme on appelle les
gendarmes